Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history um we are continuing our tour through all the various countries that have qualified for this year's football world cup and today dominic it is probably the england fans favorite opponent it's the germans yes it it is to the england football fan what australia is to the england cricket fan um the team that always seems to beat us um and which therefore we particularly like to defeat ourselves um and i guess that that also applies to world wars doesn't it i can't believe
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及深受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。呃，我们正在继续我们对今年入围世界杯的各个国家的巡礼。多米尼克，今天我们要聊的是英格兰球迷最喜欢的对手——德国队。是的，对英格兰足球迷来说，这就好比澳大利亚队对英格兰板球迷一样，呃，那支总是能击败我们的球队，正因如此，我们自己特别喜欢战胜他们……而且我猜这同样适用于世界大战，不是吗？我简直不敢相信
you went there that's i did i did i saw that joke looming yeah but like a you're like a shaven headed yeah hooligan on the terraces but but dominic i'm now going to um i'm now going to soft soap that because you have chosen for us today it is a second world war focus it is 1940s story yeah but it, yeah. But it's not the kind of perspective that one might be expecting. It's a positive perspective. It's about good Germans. Exactly. So I want to start on a particular day, Tom. I want to start in
你竟然提了这个。我提了，我确实提了。我看到这个笑话在逼近，对，但就像一个剃着光头、呃，在看台上的足球流氓一样。不过多米尼克，我现在要、呃，我现在要打圆场了，因为你今天为我们选择的主题是二战焦点，这是一个关于20世纪40年代的故事。对，但是，对，但这不是人们可能期待的那种视角。这是一个积极的视角。它是关于善良的德国人的。没错。所以我想从一个特定的日子开始，汤姆。我想从
medias res. So I want to start in Munich on the 18th of February 1943 at the university, at the great university in Munich. And I want to start with a man called Jakob Schmidt, who was the caretaker of the building, a kind of ordinary Bavarian bloke. He is middle-aged. He is a loyal Nazi party member, very keen party member, in fact.
“故事高潮切入”（in medias res）开始。所以我想从1943年2月18日的慕尼黑开始，在大学里，在慕尼黑那所伟大的大学里。我想从一个叫雅各布·施密特（Jakob Schmidt）的人开始，他是那栋建筑的看门人，一个普通的巴伐利亚老百姓。他正值中年。他是一个忠诚的纳粹党员，事实上是一个非常热心的党员。
And he's the caretaker. It's a lovely kind of warm, sort of early spring day, sort of unseasonably warm. So all is right with the world as he sees it. And the war's not going very well, of course, because the Germans have had very bad news from Stalingrad. But he's just sort of minding his own business as the caretaker of the building. The students have all arrived. They've gone into their lectures and their classes and about 11 o'clock two people come into the great sort of hall the great inner courtyard which has this great glass vaulted ceiling. And he looks up, Jakob Schmidt, and he sees that these two people who he barely looked at, a young man and a young woman, are throwing pieces of paper, throwing leaflets down from the gallery of this university sort of lobby.
他是那里的看门人。那是一个可爱、温暖的早春日子，气温异常的暖暖的。所以在他的眼里，世界一切都很好。当然，战争进展得并不顺利，因为德国人在斯大林格勒传来了非常糟糕的消息。但他只是作为这栋建筑的看门人，安分守己地做着自己的事。学生们都到了。他们去听讲座和上课了，大约11点钟，两个人走进了那个大厅，那个有着巨大玻璃拱顶天花板的大内庭院。雅各布·施密特抬起头，他看到这两个他几乎没怎么注意的人——一个年轻男子和一个年轻女子——正在把纸片、传单从这个大学大堂的二楼回廊上扔下来。
And he stares up at them and he shouts, stop, you know, you're under arrest or words to that effect, because he's so shocked at them throwing this stuff around. And at that very moment, the lecture halls, it's the end of the lectures. So the doors fly open and suddenly there are people everywhere, you know, students coming out of the lectures. So the doors fly open and suddenly there are people everywhere, you know, students coming out of the lectures. And the two people that he's shouting at start to come down the stairs to kind of lose themselves amid the crowd. But Jakob Schmidt is a man of great assiduousness. So he keeps his eyes on them. He pushes his way through the crowds and he manages to catch up with them and force his way to them grab them and he shouts
他抬头盯着他们喊道：“住手，你知道的，你们被捕了”或者类似的话，因为他们到处乱撒这些东西，他太震惊了。就在那一刻，演讲大厅里，讲座结束了。所以大门突然敞开了，到处都是人，你知道的，学生们从讲座里涌了出来。所以大门突然敞开了，到处都是人，你知道的，学生们从讲座里涌了出来。他正冲着大喊的那两个人开始走下楼梯，试图在人群中隐匿自己。但雅各布·施密特是一个非常一丝不苟的人。所以他紧盯着他们，在人群中挤过去，设法追上了他们，强行靠近并抓住他们，然后他又喊了一声
again stop you're under arrest and everybody around is appalled wondering what's going on and they don't try and run away they just um they just stand there you know like they're frozen like they've suddenly all the fight has gone out of them and he takes the two of them and he drags them away to the university rector's office. And it's there that the authorities find out who they are. And they are a brother and sister called Hans and Sophie Scholl. And that's what this podcast is about. It's about the story of Hans and Sophie Scholl and the White Rose resistance movement, which they were a part, and how they came to be there at the Munich University building that day in 1943, throwing their leaflets around and about what happened to them afterwards. So, Tom, you've probably heard a little bit about their story. A very, very inspiring story.
“住手，你们被捕了”，周围所有人都惊呆了，不知道发生了什么。他们没有试图逃跑，只是，呃，他们只是站在那里，就像冻僵了一样，就像所有的斗志突然都从他们身上抽离了一样。他抓住这两人，把他们拖到了大学校长的办公室。正是在那里，当局查明了他们的身份。他们是一对兄妹，叫汉斯和苏菲·索尔（Hans and Sophie Scholl）。这就是本期播客的主题。它讲述的是汉斯和苏菲·索尔以及他们曾参与的“白玫瑰”（White Rose）抵抗运动的故事，讲述了他们在1943年那个日子是如何来到慕尼黑大学大楼四处散发传单的，以及他们后来遭遇了什么。所以，汤姆，你大概也听说过一些他们的故事。这是一个非常、非常励志的故事。
Yeah. And incredible displays of courage. And they're very, very young, aren't they? Sophie is 22 i think when she yes exactly and she and hans is a little bit older exactly exactly right they're students so i was thinking in dominion thinking writing about them i wanted a few bites of yeah i did and decided to go for tolkien instead right okay well but but it's it's a great story and very interesting for what it says about the relationship of devout Christians to the Nazi regime.
是的。展现了令人难以置信的勇气。而且他们非常非常年轻，对吧？苏菲当时大概22岁，如果我没记…对，完全正确。而汉斯稍微年长一点。完全正确，他们是学生。所以我当时在想，多米尼克，在考虑写他们时，我本来想用几口，呃，是的，我确实想过，最后决定换成托尔金。好吧，不过，但这是一个很棒的故事，而且对于它所揭示的虔诚基督徒与纳粹政权的关系，具有非常有趣的意义。
Exactly. So who are they? So Hans had been born in 1918, Sophie in 1921. So as you say, they're in their early 20s. They're the children of Robert and Magdalena Scholl. So Robert Scholl, their father, he had been a mayor in some small towns in Swabia in southwestern Germany. He's a big and very German-looking man. He's a tax consultant, so not exactly the most... No offense to our tax consultant fans or listeners, but perhaps not the most glamorous.
没错。那么他们是谁呢？汉斯出生于1918年，苏菲出生于1921年。所以如你所说，他们刚二十出头。他们是罗伯特和玛格达莱娜·索尔（Robert and Magdalena Scholl）的孩子。他们的父亲罗伯特·索尔曾是德国西南部施瓦本（Swabia）一些小镇的市长。他是一个身材魁梧、外表极具德国特色的人。他是一名税务顾问，所以算不上最……无意冒犯我们当税务顾问的粉丝或听众，但这或许算不上最光鲜亮丽的职业。
We don't normally talk about tax consultants, except for the Emperor Anastasius. Yes, very much a friend of the show. Yeah, or I suppose Antonio Salazar. But Robert Scholl, their father. So their mother, Magdalena, was a Protestant nurse, and Protestantism is very important to her. Their father, he's also a man of a very sort of strong inner conviction.
我们平时不怎么聊税务顾问，除了皇帝阿纳斯塔修斯（Emperor Anastasius）。是的，绝对是节目的老熟人了。对，或者我想安东尼奥·萨拉查（Antonio Salazar）。不过说到他们的父亲罗伯特·索尔。他们的母亲玛格达莱娜是一名新教护士，新教对她来说非常重要。他们的父亲也是一个有着非常强烈内心信念的人。
So in the First World War, Robert Scholl had actually been a pacifist, and he'd worked as a medic, so he hadn't seen action. He'd done his bit for his country, but he didn't believe in violence. There's a word in German for somebody with, like Robert Scholl, they call them an Einzelgänger, a man who goes his own way, the man who goes on his own. So Nazis are not keen on that? Not at all, not at all.
所以在第一次世界大战中，罗伯特·索尔其实是一名和平主义者，他曾作为一名医疗兵服役，所以他没有亲历过前线战斗。他为国家尽了自己的一份力，但他不相信暴力。德语里有一个词用来形容像罗伯特·索尔这样的人，他们称之为“独行者”（Einzelgänger），一个走自己路的人，一个独行的人。所以纳粹不喜欢这种人？一点也不，完全不喜欢。
However, Hans and Sophie, they're respectively, Hans is 14 and Sophie is 12, when the Nazis come to power in Germany at the beginning of the 1930s. And they both join with their sisters. They've got two sisters and a brother. The sister's Inge and Elisabeth, and their brother is Werner. And they join the Hitler Youth, like so many children and teenagers do in the 1930s.
然而，当纳粹在20世纪30年代初在德国掌权时，汉斯和苏菲分别——汉斯14岁，苏菲12岁。他们和姐妹们一起加入了组织。他们有两个姐妹和一个兄弟。姐妹叫英格（Inge）和伊丽莎白（Elisabeth），兄弟叫维纳（Werner）。他们加入了希特勒青年团（Hitler Youth），就像30年代的许多儿童和青少年一样。
They love it, don't they? Yeah, they do, because they think, like so many, again, like so many, they think it's a great lark, very exciting. You get to dress up. So the Hitler Youth, to give you a sense of its great explosion, the end of 1932, it had about 100,000 members. By 1935, it had 4 million. And a lot of that is obviously sort of coercion and getting in with the regime and all that sort of stuff.
他们很喜欢，对吧？是的，他们确实很喜欢，因为他们和其他许多人一样，认为这是一场盛大的恶作剧，非常令人兴奋。你可以盛装打扮。所以为了让你对希特勒青年团的空前爆发有个概念，在1932年底，它大约有10万名成员。到1935年，它拥有了400万成员。这其中很大一部分显然是通过胁迫、融入政权以及诸如此类的手段实现的。
But as you absolutely say, they're given a chance to dress up in uniforms. They get to go on torch-lit processions. And they genuinely believe that they're rebuilding Germany. So their sister Inge. They're only 12, aren't they? Right. They're still 12. So their sister Inga said later, we heard so much talk about the fatherland and comradeship,
但正如你所说的那样，他们有机会穿上制服。他们可以参加火炬游行。他们真心相信他们正在重建德国。他们的姐姐英格曾说过——他们当时只有12岁，对吧？对。他们当时才12岁。所以他们的姐姐英格后来回忆说：“我们听到了太多关于祖国和同志情谊的谈论，”
the Volk community and the love of one's home. This impressed us and we listened with rapture. We were told that we should live for something greater than ourselves. And we were taken seriously in a strange sort of way. And you can sort of see that because the Nazis are saying to children and teenagers, you're very important. This new Germany belongs to you. Join the torch lit processions, dress up, come're very important. This new Germany belongs to you. Join the torch-lit processions.
人民共同体（Volksgemeinschaft）以及对家乡的热爱。这打动了我们，我们听得如痴如醉。我们被告知，我们应该为比自身更伟大的事物而活。而且在某种奇怪的意义上，我们被认真对待了。你可以理解这一点，因为纳粹在对儿童和青少年说：你们非常重要。这个新德国属于你们。加入火炬游行，盛装打扮，来吧——你们非常重要。这个新德国属于你们。加入火炬游行。
Dress up. Come on the camps. It's going to be great fun. And Hans, he's really into this. Sophie's into it too. She loves all the hiking. She's very romantic, very idealistic. She writes.
盛装打扮。来参加营地活动。这会非常有趣。汉斯对此真的很热衷。苏菲也很热衷。她喜欢所有的徒步旅行。她非常浪漫，非常理想主义。她会写作。
There's this great tradition of kind of young people in Germany in the early 20th century getting out and enjoying nature and going on these sort of walks all together and this sort of collective recreation and stuff she loves all this now their father thinks it's terrible he's not a man he's not especially left-wing he's's not somebody who had been pretty disgusted by what he saw as the corruption of the Weimar Republic. But he hates the Nazis. He says to his children, they are wolves. They are wild beasts.
在20世纪初的德国，有一种伟大的传统：年轻人走出去享受大自然，一起进行这种徒步旅行，以及这种集体休闲活动等等。她非常喜欢这一切。现在，他们的父亲觉得这太可怕了。他不是那种人，他也不是特别左翼，他不是那种对魏玛共和国的腐败感到十分厌恶的人。但他讨厌纳粹。他对他的孩子们说：他们是狼。他们是野兽。
They are misusing the German people terribly. But his children don't listen. They're all in on the Hitler Youth, particularly Hans. So Hans, not long after he joins joins he's made a kind of squad leader and in a way i mean there's some listeners may think this is a terrible comparison but i don't think it's entirely inappropriate in a way for people like hands it's a bit like joining the boy scouts but that's i mean that's a that's a parallel that is made at the time isn't it i mean it's very you know dressing up in uniforms and learning how to build fires and things.
他们在极其恶劣地荼毒德国人民。但他的孩子们不听。他们全都加入了希特勒青年团，尤其是汉斯。所以汉斯在加入后不久，就被提升为一个分队队长。从某种意义上说——有些听众可能会觉得这是一个糟糕的类比，但我认为并非完全不恰当——对于汉斯这样的人来说，这有点像加入童子军。不过，那是当时人们做出的一个类比，不是吗？我的意思是，这非常，你知道的，穿上制服，学习如何生火之类的事情。
Right, whittling wood, exactly, all of that. So Hans, as he's a squad leader, he organises evenings in the clubhouse. They will put on the radio and they will listen, you know, a bit of modernity amid all the kind of wood whittling. And they will listen to the official programs of the Hitler Youth. They will listen to the message. And he never questions this until, interestingly, he goes to the Nuremberg rally in 1936. And he is chosen because he's such a big,
没错，削木头，绝对的，所有这些。所以汉斯作为分队队长，他在俱乐部里组织晚会。他们会打开收音机收听——在削木头之余感受一点现代气息。他们会收听希特勒青年团的官方节目。他们会倾听那些信息。他从未对此产生过怀疑，直到有趣的是，他在1936年去了纽伦堡集会。他被选中了，因为他是一个如此高大、
sort of a bigwig by teenage standards, a binoc. He is chosen to carry the banner of the Ulm, because they're from the city of Ulm, of the Ulm Hitler Youth Section. And everyone says, of course, they've chosen the Hans. He's so handsome. He loves all this kind of thing. But when he comes back from Nuremberg, the people in his family say it's as though something had sort of changed, that he had... So how old is he at this point?
按青少年标准算是个大人物的家伙，一个“小头目”（binoc）。他被选中为乌尔姆（Ulm）举旗，因为他们来自乌尔姆市，代表乌尔姆的希特勒青年团支队。每个人都说，理所当然的，他们选中了汉斯。他长得太英俊了。他热爱所有这类事情。但当他从纽伦堡回来时，他的家人说，就好像有什么东西发生了变化，他……那么他此时多大年纪？
So this is 1936, and he was born in 1918. So in other words, he's 18. Yeah. Okay, so he's old enough to start... To start thinking, exactly, yeah. And he said later to one of his sisters that he didn't like the fact that when he was at Nuremberg, there was no time and no opportunity to have proper conversations and debates about the future of Germany, that they were just sort of told what to do. And they were being, you know, that it was all mindless.
所以这是1936年，他出生于1918年。换句话说，他18岁了。好的，所以他已经到了开始……开始思考的年纪了，完全正确，是的。他后来对他的一个姐姐说，他不喜欢在纽伦堡时，没有时间和机会就德国的未来进行适当的对话和辩论，他们只是被告知该做什么。而且他们当时正在经历，你知道的，这一切都是盲目的。
You know, the Scholl children are terribly idealistic. They're great ones for kind of not only going on these massive nature walks, but also sitting around and talking about the meaning of life. And with their parents. With their parents. And he goes to Nuremberg. And I think there's parts of Hans that thinks, when I go there, that's what we'll be doing. But I mean, so one of the things about totalitarianism and particularly Nazi totalitarianism is absolutely the idea that the family should not be a safe space for private conversations, should it? Absolutely. Absolutely. I mean, they have the problem of the fact that their father, who they revere in many ways, who is this very inspiring man who goes his own way, that their father has made completely plain to them that he despises the
你知道，索尔家的孩子们非常理想主义。他们不仅热衷于进行这些大规模的自然徒步旅行，还喜欢坐在一起讨论生命的意义。而且是和他们的父母一起。和他们的父母一起。他去了纽伦堡。我想汉斯心里有一部分以为，当我到那儿时，我们就会做那些事。但我的意思是，极权主义的一个特点，尤其是纳粹极权主义，绝对是这种观点：家庭不应该成为私人谈话的安全空间，对吧？绝对是的。绝对是的。我的意思是，他们面临这样一个问题：他们的父亲——他们在很多方面都崇敬的这个人，这个走自己路的、极其鼓舞人心的人——他们的父亲已经向他们明确表示，他鄙视
Nazis and is horrified by the fact that they're throwing themselves into this. But there's a couple of other things as well. So one of them is that at some point, Hans was caught reading the books of Stefan Zweig, the great Jewish writer. And he clearly liked Stefan Zweig's, I assume his short stories, which are so fantastically readable and brilliant, perfectly formed. And he was obviously told by somebody, this is no good. He's a Jewish writer. And that made, that gave him kind of pause. But apparently, I mean, this,
纳粹，并对他们投身其中感到惊恐万分。但除此之外还有其他一些事情。其中之一就是，有一次汉斯被抓到在读斯蒂芬·茨威格（Stefan Zweig）的书，这位伟大的犹太作家。他显然很喜欢茨威格的——我猜是他的短篇小说，那些读起来妙趣横生、才华横溢、结构完美的作品。他显然被某个人告知了：这可不行。他是个犹太作家。这让他，让他陷入了某种沉思。但显然，我的意思是，这，
I'm basing this on a wonderful book about the Scholl family by Annette Dumbach and Judd Newborn, which I recommend to listeners because it's a brilliant window into their kind of world. This is the kind of thing that will sound so banal, but you can completely see how to a teenager,
我是基于安内特·杜姆巴赫（Annette Dumbach）和贾德·纽伯恩（Judd Newborn）所著的那本关于索尔一族的精彩著作得出的结论，我向听众推荐这本书，因为它是了解他们那个世界的一扇极好的窗户。这种事情听起来可能很陈腐，但你完全可以理解，对于一个青少年来说，
it would be a massive deal. He decides that he's going to, he'd carried the banner at the Nuremberg rally. And when he gets back to Ulm, he decides that as a project for his squad, they're going to design their own special banner and it will make them stand
这会是一件大事。他决定——他在纽伦堡集会上扛过旗帜。当他回到乌尔姆后，他决定作为他分队的一个项目，他们要设计自己的特殊旗帜，这会让他们脱颖
out. And he designs this very colorful banner of a Griffin. And basically they go out in Ulm with their Griffin banner and some other sort of Hitler youth bigwigs come see them and are shocked and tear it down. And Hans is really offended and he has a fight. And they tear it down, not because they're offended by griffins, but because it's displaying individuality of thought. No, they've got nothing against griffins because it's individualism.
而出。他设计了这面色彩斑斓的狮鹫（Griffin）旗帜。基本上，他们带着他们的狮鹫旗走上乌尔姆街头，其他一些希特勒青年团的大人物看到后大为震惊，并把旗帜撕毁了。汉斯非常生气，并和人打了一架。他们撕毁旗帜，不是因为他们对狮鹫有什么意见，而是因为这展现了个体思想。不，他们对狮鹫没有任何意见，是因为这是个人主义。
Yeah, because it's broken with the, you know, it's not what you're meant to have. And Hans is really shocked by this. And he has a fight with this bloke in the street. And from that point onwards, it's as though something within him is kind of broken. And his faith in the party and in the mission and the enterprise. You wouldn't want to live in a country where you can't have a Griffin banner. I definitely wouldn't, Tom. Yes. and that's merely scratching the surface the full iniquities yes um so hansen and sophie they start to sort of fall out of love with the regimes there's a there's an
对，因为这打破了，你知道的，这不是你本该有的样子。汉斯对此感到非常震惊。他在街上跟这个家伙打了一架。从那一刻起，就好像他内心有什么东西破碎了。他对党、对使命和事业的信仰破灭了。你可不想住在一个连狮鹫旗都不能有的国家。我绝对不想，汤姆。是的。而这仅仅是冰山一角，更多的暴行，是的……所以汉斯和苏菲开始对这个政权有些幻灭了。还有一个
issue that uh sophie has teenage girls are told that they have to have braided hair you know the sort of pigtails and stuff like they look look like a good German girl. And Sophie, she's not blonde. She doesn't want to have a sort of peasant hairstyle. She has a bob. She has a short bob. And that, again, kind of marks her out as different among, you know, how important it is for teenagers. The issue of, you know, whether you're going to conform with all the others or whether you're going to go your own way and be a different kind of person. Their father is always encouraging them to be different so there's a story that
问题，那就是苏菲——当时青少年女孩被告知她们必须编头发，你知道那种双马辫之类的，看起来像个优秀的德国女孩。而苏菲，她不是金发。她不想弄那种村姑似的发型。她留着波波头（bob）。她留着短短的波波头。这再次让她在同龄人中显得与众不同，你知道，这对于青少年来说有多重要：你是要随大流，还是走自己的路，做一个与众不同的人。他们的父亲总是鼓励他们与众不同，所以有一个故事说，
they were once going for a walk along the river around the banks of the danube and robert shull said to his children all that i want for you is to walk straight and free through life even when it's hard we we talked didn't we in our episode on teenagers a long time ago about how there was this trend under the Nazis for some teenagers to kind of, I guess they were kind of prototypical teenagers. They were exploring the excitement of being different. The idea that to be different was what being a teenager is all about. Yes. Yes. There's groups called, there's the Navajos. There's a group called the Black Gang. There's a group called the Edelweiss Pirates. And they do things like they grow their hair or they wear sort of Czech shirts, sort of American-style shirts.
有一次他们沿着多瑙河岸边散步，罗伯特·索尔对他的孩子们说：“我对你们唯一的期望，就是正直而自由地走过一生，哪怕道路艰难。”我们很久以前在关于青少年的那一期节目里谈论过，在纳粹统治下，当时有一种潮流，一些青少年，我猜他们是某种原型的青少年。他们在探索与众不同的刺激感。那种认为“与众不同”正是青少年全部意义所在的观念。是的。是的。有一些组织，比如纳瓦霍帮（Navajos）。有一个组织叫黑帮（Black Gang）。有一个组织叫雪绒花海盗（Edelweiss Pirates）。他们会做一些事情，比如留长发，或者穿捷克衬衫、美式风格的衬衫。
They listen to swing music. British jazz, American jazz. And they mock the Hitler Youth. They say, oh, look at all those kind of drones just sort of trudging along behind their banners. Absolutely that. There's another issue. Sophie has a Stefan Zweig-style moment. They are asked in one of their group meetings,
他们听摇摆乐。英国爵士乐，美国爵士乐。他们嘲笑希特勒青年团。他们说：“哦，看那些拖着旗帜慢吞吞行进的行尸走肉。”绝对是这样。还有一个问题。苏菲经历了一个斯蒂芬·茨威格式的时刻。他们在一次小组会议上被问到：
should we talk about literature? Should we talk about some of your favorite writers? And she says, oh, brilliant. I'll bring in some poems by Heinrich Heine, who's one of my favorite writers. And there's a sort of dead, horrified silence because Heine is Jewish and she's horrified. You know,
我们应该谈论文学吗？我们应该谈谈你们最喜欢的一些作家吗？她说：“哦，太棒了。我要带一些海因里希·海涅（Heinrich Heine）的诗来，他是我最喜欢的作家之一。”接着是一片死寂般的、惊恐的沉默，因为海涅是犹太人，而她感到震惊。你知道的，
Heine's books have actually been banned by Goebbels. So again, you know, this is, this marks her out as, as unusual. So by, as we approach the sort of the end of the 1930s,
海涅的书其实已经被戈培尔查禁了。所以再次说明，这，这让她显得异于常人。因此，随着我们接近20世纪30年代末，
they're fallen out of love with the Hitler youth And Hans actually joins one of these sort of subcultural kind of teenage groups. It's a group called DJ111. And that stands for the German Youth of November the 1st, 1929. And that was the day that the founder of the group had been abroad and he'd come back to Germany. He decided to set up a youth group actually to counter what he saw as the rise of the Nazis and the Hitler youth. And so this group that Hans joins in Ulm, to give you a sense of the kind of things they do, they love hitchhiking. They love Balkan folk songs. They play the Russian balalaikaika so they're kind of they're cosmopolitan they're deliberately cosmopolitan they use or they write all in lowercase letters now that makes out a tiny thing but that's what the bauhaus did so that's a very sort of bauhausy kind of weimar republic-y kind of gesture also i mean we talked about the banner another thing they do is they have um there's a big deal among these sort of German youth groups about having their tents, that kind of military-like style again, marks you out as different, as going against the norm, as going against the sort of established pattern.
他们对希特勒青年团彻底幻灭了。汉斯实际上加入了其中一个亚文化式的青少年群体。那是一个叫做DJ111的组织。这代表着“1929年11月1日德国青年”（German Youth of November the 1st, 1929）。那是该组织的创始人曾在国外待过、回到德国的日子。他决定建立一个青年组织，实际上是为了对抗他所看到的纳粹和希特勒青年团的崛起。所以汉斯在乌尔姆加入的这个组织——为了让你对他们做的事情有个概念——他们喜欢搭便车。他们喜欢巴尔干民歌。他们弹奏俄罗斯巴拉莱卡琴（balalaika），所以他们有点像——他们是国际化的，刻意保持国际化。他们全部使用或书写小写字母。现在这听起来像是一件微不足道的小事，但包豪斯（Bauhaus）就是这么做的，所以这是一种非常具有包豪斯风格、魏玛共和国风格的姿态。还有，我的意思是，我们讨论过旗帜，他们做的另一件事是——这些德国青年组织非常热衷于拥有自己的帐篷，那种军事般的风格再次让他们显得与众不同，对抗常规，对抗既定模式。
So anyway, Hans is involved with that. That's all fine. War breaks out in the end of 1939. Hans is studying in Munich, but he's doing his medical studies. He is sent into France as a medic. Sophie has a boyfriend by this point called Fritz Hardnagel. He ends up serving later on in the Eastern Front. Sophie spends time working in kindergartens.
总之，汉斯参与了其中。这都还好。1939年底战争爆发。汉斯在慕尼黑学习，但他攻读的是医学专业。他被派往法国担任医疗兵。此时苏菲有了一个男朋友，名叫弗里茨·哈特纳格尔（Fritz Hartnagel）。他后来在东线服役。苏菲花时间在幼儿园工作。
She's sent to a munitions factory, and she's shocked by what she finds in the munitions factory. What shocked her? She doesn't get on with the other girls. It sort of fuels her sense of individualism. Right. So she doesn't like the fact that the other girls are... She doesn't like the regimented nature of it, the fact that they're being bossed around, the fact that it's sort of militaristic hierarchy. She doesn't like the fact that the other girls don't like discussing ideas,
她被派去一家军工厂，她在军工厂里的所见所闻让她大受震撼。是什么震惊了她？她和别的女孩合不来。这助长了她的个人主义意识。对。所以她不喜欢别的女孩……她不喜欢那种体制化的性质，不喜欢她们被人吆喝来吆喝去，不喜欢那种军国主义等级制度。她不喜欢别的女孩不喜欢讨论思想，
that they don't question the regime, that they don't have this kind of restless, idealistic side that the Scholls have been taught to do. I mean, again, books are really important. After Lights Out, she reads Thomas Mann's The Magic Mountain by Torchlight. That's not a Nazi. That's not a Nazi. That's not a Nazi book. No, not at all.
不喜欢质疑政权，不喜欢拥有索尔兄妹被教导要拥有的那种不安分的、理想主义的一面。我的意思是，书本同样非常重要。熄灯之后，她在火炬光下阅读托马斯·曼（Thomas Mann）的《魔山》（The Magic Mountain）。那可不是一本纳粹的书。那不是一本纳粹书。那不是纳粹的书。不，一点也不。
I mean, Mann is in exile at this point and is very much, you know, and he is absolutely an enemy of the Third Reich. And they are more and more, they're questioning the regime, but also the war. So Sophie says at one point, well writes to her her fiance fritz who's out on um on the eastern front she writes if you one believes in the victory of might one also has to believe that men are on the same level as animals which is what the nazis think on one level but they also believe that humans are just an animal like any other. Yeah, exactly right. So just as we come towards the break, early 1942, so that's a year before where we started this podcast,
我的意思是，曼此时正处于流亡之中，非常明确地，你知道的，他绝对是第三帝国的敌人。他们越来越多地质疑政权，同时也质疑这场战争。所以苏菲在某个时刻说——或者说写信给她的未婚夫弗里茨，当时他在东线——她写道：“如果一个人相信力量的胜利，那他也必须相信人类和动物处于同一水平。”这正是纳粹在一层面上所想的，但他们同时也认为人类不过是和别的动物一样的动物。是的，完全正确。所以在我们迎来中场休息之际，时间来到了1942年初，也就是我们这期播客开始的一年前，
that finds Hans in Munich where he is studying at the university. So he's come back from France. He's studying with the university. He's got in with a little group of medical students. So, I mean, this isn't, The White Rose isn't just the story of hansen so
汉斯当时在慕尼黑，在大学里学习。所以他从法国回来了。他在大学里学习。他加入了一个由医学生组成的小团体。所以，我的意思是，这不是——“白玫瑰”不仅仅是汉斯和苏菲的故事，
it's often reduced to that but they have friends christoph probst villi graf alexander schmorl they are all what unites them is they're all influenced by and deeply interested in kind of christian ideas so they are your level this time you'd love this that's yeah because she's she's very keen on saint augustine right i was just about to say they're reading augustine's confessions they read thomas aquinas they read french catholic writers which is interesting because they're lutheran i mean they're from a protestant background but they're clearly very influenced by catholic but munich is very catholic yeah so they have a friend called villi graf he is a very very keen catholic he has been incredibly religious since he was actually a little boy and and actually when hitler took power when he was 15 their friend villi he wrote a huge
人们常常把它简化为仅仅是他们俩的故事，但他们还有朋友：克里斯托夫·普斯特（Christoph Probst）、维利·格拉夫（Willi Graf）、亚历山大·施莫雷尔（Alexander Schmorell）。他们共同的一点是，他们都受到基督教思想的影响并对其深感兴趣。你会喜欢这个的，汤姆，你一定会喜欢这个，对，因为她非常热衷于圣奥古斯丁。没错，我正要说呢，他们在阅读奥古斯丁的《忏悔录》（Confessions），在阅读托马斯·阿奎那（Thomas Aquinas），在阅读法国天主教作家的作品。这很有趣，因为他们是路德宗信徒——我的意思是，他们出身于新教背景——但他们显然深受天主教的影响。不过慕尼黑是一个非常天主教的城市，是的。所以他们有一个朋友叫维利·格拉夫，他是一个非常、非常虔诚的天主教徒。他从小到大都极其虔诚，
list of all his friends and then he crossed out then he crossed out on the list the names of all those who joined the hitler youth and he never spoke to any of them again but that would have included uh the shoals wouldn't it well it would have included the shoals ironically if he'd known them at the time and they have another friend alex schmorrell he's a fascinating person so he had been born in russia then he moved back to germany he was absolutely obsessed with russian culture and at the end of his life i mean after he was dead he was actually canonized as an orth saint. Blimey. So in other words, just to give you, before we go into the break, to give you a portrait of these guys. So these are Hans's friends.
事实上，当希特勒掌权时，他才15岁，他们的朋友维利列了一张巨大无比的清单，上面写着他所有朋友的名字。然后他在清单上划掉了——划掉了所有加入希特勒青年团的人的名字，并且再也没有跟他们中的任何一个人说过话。但这其中会包括索尔兄妹吧？如果他当时认识他们的话，讽刺的是，确实会包括索尔兄妹。他们还有另一个朋友，亚历克斯·施莫雷尔（Alex Schmorell）。他是一个极具魅力的人。他出生在俄罗斯，后来搬回了德国。他绝对痴迷于俄罗斯文化。在他生命的尽头——也就是他死后，他实际上被追认为了一位正教会的圣徒。天哪。换句话说，为了给你——在我们进入中场休息之前，为了给你勾勒一下这些家伙的肖像。所以这些是汉斯的朋友。
They are intensely serious. I mean, I can't honestly say that they'd be the people I'd be friends with if I was at university, because I'm obviously far too unserious to get involved with this sort of group. They're much more impressive people, I think, than I am, Tom, and maybe even than you. They are reading Thomas Aquinas, they're reading St. Augustine, they're questioning the regime. You see, the thing is, I'm sure one of the reasons they're doing that is because in the context of Nazism, Christianity has become so countercultural. Yeah, absolutely. I'm sure that's right. That it's actually cooler than it would be in 2020s Britain.
他们极其严肃。说实话，我不能老实说，如果我在上大学时，他们会是我交的朋友，因为我显然太不够严肃了，没法参与这种类型的群体。汤姆，我觉得他们比我 impressive（令人钦佩）得多，也许甚至比你还要厉害。他们在读托马斯·阿奎那，在读圣奥古斯丁，他们在质疑政权。你看，问题在于，我确信他们这么做的一个原因是因为在纳粹主义的语境下，基督教已经变得如此具有反主流文化色彩。是的，绝对是的。我确信正是如此。以至于它实际上比2020年代的英国还要酷。
Because what I found was, reading around this subject, was that there was a sense in which, particularly Lutheran Christianity, I think, but also to a degree, I mean, all Christianity full stop, comes to seem pallid to people in comparison with the glamour and the swagger of Nazism, which is itself influenced quite strongly by Catholic ritual. And there is a sense in which German Christianity under the Third Reich becomes, I mean, in Dominion, I described them as becoming like the Nazgul. The church becomes a spectral thing. But for those who are standing firm against Nazism, Christianity provides a sense of colour and depth and purpose that otherwise would be much harder for them to find, to get purchase on. And so the story of the churches under Nazism is simultaneously, you know, they
因为我发现，在围绕这个主题进行阅读时，我有一种感觉，特别是路德宗基督教，但也在一定程度上——我的意思是，基督教整体而言——与纳粹主义的光鲜亮丽和飞扬跋扈相比，在人们看来变得苍白无力，而纳粹主义本身受天主教仪式的强烈影响。在某种程度上，第三帝国之下的德国基督教变成了——我在《多米尼克三部曲/王权与信仰》（Dominion）里把它们形容得像戒灵（Nazgul）。教会变成了一种幽灵般的存在。但对于那些坚守立场反对纳粹主义的人来说，基督教提供了一种色彩、深度和目的感，否则他们很难在其他地方找到或获得支撑。因此，纳粹统治下教会的历史，一方面是它们
become Nazgul, but also unbelievably inspires unbelievable heroism. Yeah. Well, we'll come inspires unbelievable heroism. Yeah. Well, we'll come to the heroism after the break, because in the first week of May 1942, Sophie arrives to join her brother in Munich. He meets her off the train. He takes her to Schwabing, the place where the students will hang out in the cafes and their discussion groups and their lodgings and all that sort of stuff. And just a few weeks later, their lives are going to change completely. And we'll find out what happens after the break.
变成了戒灵，但另一方面也激发了令人难以置信的、不可思议的英雄主义。是的，我们会在中场休息后聊聊这种英雄主义。因为在1942年5的第一周，苏菲抵达慕尼黑与她哥哥会合。他在火车站接了她。他把她带到施瓦宾（Schwabing），那是学生们在咖啡馆、讨论小组和住所等地闲逛的地方。仅仅几周后，他们的生活将彻底改变。我们在中场休息后揭晓接下来发生了什么。
We'll be back soon. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我们很快回来。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和八分八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家播客和抢先购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Dominic is taking us through the dramatic and heroic story of the Scholls. Dominic, Sophie has just arrived in Munich. She has joined Hans, her brother. What happens next? She gets in with her brother's friends and the days pass. Just a few weeks after her arrival in the Bavarian city, a leaflet or multiple copies of a leaflet appear in Munich. Now the leaflets are, they're typed, they're single spaced on two sides of a sheet of paper and they're folded into envelopes and they're posted across the city to a very, very random group of people. So academics get them, civil
你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。多米尼克正带领我们了解索尔兄妹惊心动魄、充满英雄主义的故事。多米尼克，苏菲刚刚抵达慕尼黑。她和哥哥汉斯团聚了。接下来发生了什么？她加入了她哥哥的朋友圈，日子一天天过去。就在她抵达这座巴伐利亚城市几周后，慕尼黑出现了一份传单，或者说是一份传单的多份复印件。这些传单是用打字机单倍行距打在纸张正反两面上的，它们被折叠进信封里，并被寄给慕尼黑市一组非常、非常随机的人。所以学者们会收到，公务员会收到，
servants, but also people who own restaurants. They're sent to pubs. They're just sent to shops. They're sent just randomly to people and to addresses across the city. And these leaflets are signed by a group called the White Rose. Now, where that name comes from, nobody knows. There had been a novel called the White Rose a few years earlier, published in Berlin, by the author of the Treasure of the Sierra Madre, the great, later made into a Hollywood film, kind of piratical romance.
还有餐馆老板。它们被寄到酒吧。它们被寄到商店。它们被随机寄给这座城市里的人和各个地址。这些传单由一个名为“白玫瑰”的组织署名。至于这个名字从何而来，无人知晓。几年前柏林曾出版过一本名为《白玫瑰》的小说，作者是《碧血金沙》（The Treasure of the Sierra Madre）的作者——这部伟大作品后来被拍成好莱坞电影，是一部海盗式的传奇小说。
But maybe the title came from there, we don't know. The leaflets are burning with passion against the regime so the very first leaflets to give you an indication it says every individual has to consciously accept his responsibility as a member of western and christian civilization in this last hour to arm himself as best he can to work against the scourge of humanity against fascism and every other form of the absolute state adopt passive resistance resistance wherever you are block the functioning of this atheistic war machine before it is too late before our last city is a heap of rubble like cologne and before the last youth of our nation bleeds to death
但这个名字也许就来源于此，我们不得而知。这些传单充满了反对政权的炽热激情。为了让你有个概念，第一份传单上写道：“在西方和基督教文明的这最后时刻，每一个个体都必须清醒地承担起作为其中一员的责任，尽其所能武装自己，去对抗人类的祸害——法西斯主义以及一切形式的绝对国家。采取消极抵抗，在任何地方进行抵抗，在这个 atheistic（无神论的）战争机器运转得太迟之前、在我们最后的城市变成像科隆那样的废墟之前、在我们民族最后的青年因一个次人类的狂妄自大而流尽最后一滴血之前，瘫痪它的运作。”
because of the hubris of a subhuman. So, Sophie doesn't know who's produced the leaflets. The truth, of course, is that her brother and his friends have been producing them. They decided earlier that summer that they really need to do something, to make some kind of gesture against the Nazi regime. They earn a decent amount of money. They earn 250 Reichsmarks a month, which is more than most workers earn. And they pool all their money. They bought a
所以，苏菲并不知道是谁制作了这些传单。当然，事实是她的哥哥和他的朋友们一直在制作这些传单。他们在那年夏天早些时候决定，他们真的必须做点什么，针对纳粹政权做出某种姿态。他们能赚到一笔可观的钱。他们一个月能赚250国家马克，这比大多数工人赚的都要多。他们把所有的钱凑在一起。他们买了一台
duplicating machine. They bought a typewriter. They bought printing paper. They bought the stamps. They bought envelopes. They bought everything. And they have produced the leaflets themselves and just sent them out randomly to people across the city. So Sophie sees this leaflet and she takes it to Hans's room to show him. And he's not there, but lying around on his desk are all these books with quotations and things that are in the leaflets. He comes in, she says, this is a bit weird. I found this leaflet and it looks like all this stuff on your desk. And he denies it at first, but eventually he admits it. She's quite shocked initially. And she talks to his friends. And as they talk, she ends up being convinced.
复印机。他们买了一台打字机。他们买了打印纸。他们买了邮票。他们买了信封。他们买了一切东西。他们自己制作了传单，然后随机寄给全市各处的人。所以苏菲看到了这份传单，她把它拿到汉斯的房间给他看。他不在，但在他的桌上散落着许多书，上面有传单里引用的引文和内容。他进来了，她说：“这有点奇怪。我发现了这份传单，上面看起来全是你桌上的这些东西。”他起初否认，但最终承认了。她起初感到非常震惊。她和他的朋友们谈了谈。在交谈中，她最终被说服了。
And she's the only girl. She's the only girl. Yes. The rest of them are all blokes. They're all his sort of very male. The Germans love these kind of fraternities. a bit like tolkien and his group of friends it's just like tolkien and the inklings they are you know we were talking in our tolkien podcast weren't we about tolkien and his friends at king edward's birmingham who were unbelievably idealistic and serious and masculine and yeah and they were going to change the world by smoking pipes drinking beer and writing finnish style poems yes and the white rose guys they think they're going to change the world by smoking pipes drinking beer and writing finnish style poems yes and the white rose guys they think they're going to change the world by producing these very christian leaflets
而且她是唯一的女孩。她是唯一的女孩。是的。其他人都是小伙子。他们全都是他那种非常男性的朋友。德国人非常喜欢这种兄弟会。这有点像托尔金和他的朋友圈，就像托尔金和“因克林兹”（Inklings）社团一样，你知道的——我们在我们的托尔金播客里聊过，对吧，聊过托尔金和他在伯明翰爱德华国王学校的朋友们，他们极其理想主义、严肃且具有男子气概，是的，他们打算通过抽烟斗、喝啤酒和写芬兰风格的诗歌来改变世界。是的，“白玫瑰”的伙计们认为他们要通过制作这些非常基督教色彩的传单来改变世界，
attacking the nazi regime and sophie decides yeah you know i'm in i'm in i'm all in so the next leaflet number two appears a couple of weeks later, so it's the third week of June 1942. And I mean, I'm not going to read huge extracts from all the leaflets. What's striking about this leaflet is it talks about the crimes against the Jews. So it says explicitly, since the conquest of Poland, 300,000 Jews have been murdered in a bestial manner. Here we see the most terrible crime committed against the dignity of man, a crime that has no counterpart in human history. Is this a sign that the German people have become brutalized in their basic human feelings? And it goes on to say, everyone shrugs off this guilt, falling asleep with his conscience at peace, but he cannot shrug it off. Everyone is guilty,
攻击纳粹政权。而苏菲决定：好吧，我加入，我加入，我全心全意加入。所以下一份传单——第二号传单在几周后出现，也就是1942年6月的第三周。我的意思是，我不会朗读所有传单的大段摘录。这份传单引人注目的是它谈到了针对犹太人的罪行。所以它明确指出：自从征服波兰以来，已有30万犹太人以野蛮的方式遭到谋杀。在这里，我们看到了针对人类尊严的最可怕的罪行，这是人类历史上绝无仅有的。这难道是标志着德国人在其基本人类情感上已经变得野蛮化的征兆吗？它接着说：每个人都对这种罪行推卸责任，带着平静的良心入睡，但他无法推卸。每个人都有罪，
guilty, guilty. So that's leaflet number two. Then there's a third leaflet a couple of weeks later. Our state is the dictatorship of evil. The first concern of every German is not the military victory over Bolshevism, but the defeat of national socialism. And then there's one more, leaflet number four, so a few weeks after that. So this is all packed into a very short period of time, June, July 1942. Leaflet number four,
有罪，有罪。这就是第二号传单。接着几周后出现了第三号传单：“我们的国家是邪恶的独裁统治。每个德国人的首要关注点不是对布尔什维克的军事胜利，而是打倒国家社会主义。”然后还有一份，第四号传单，在几周之后。所以这一切都挤在极短的一段时间内发生，即1942年6月和7月。第四号传单——
I mean, here's your Christianity, Tom. Every word that comes from Hitler's mouth is a lie. When he says peace, he means war. When Hitler speaks of God, he really means the power of evil, the fallen angel, Satan. But it's also very Orwellian, isn't it?
我的意思是，你的基督教在这里，汤姆。从希特勒口中说出的每一个字都是谎言。当他说和平时，他指的是战争。当希特勒谈到上帝时，他实际上指的是邪恶的力量，那个堕落的天使，撒旦。但这也非常奥威尔化，不是吗？
It is, I guess it is. Yeah, it is Orwellian. You know, peace, war, all that stuff. Well, it's Tolkien fused with Orwell, the two great British novelists writing about the Second World War. I suppose you're right. I mean, it's striking how imbued it is with the Christian stuff, how important that is to them.
是的，我想是的。对，它是奥威尔式的。你知道的，和平就是战争，诸如此类。嗯，这是托尔金与奥威尔的结合，这两位伟大的英国小说家都在书写第二次世界大战。我想你是对的。我的意思是，引人注目的是它浸透了多少基督教的内容，这对他有多重要。
I don't think it's surprising. I really do think that this is, well, because Nazism is so ideologically opposed, not just to institutional Christianity, but to the moral fundamentals of Christianity as they've traditionally been understood. Sympathy for the duty of care that is owed by the strong to the weak and by the sense that there is a common human dignity that transcends gender, race, social standing, whatever. And obviously Nazism absolutely despises both those principles it does i've made a terrible error choosing this tom because this is giving you the opportunity to mount your favorite hobby horse but you're right you're absolutely right of course i mean the two things the christian emphasis on the kind of dignity of each individual human and sanctity
我认为这并不令人意外。我真的认为这是，嗯——因为纳粹主义在意识形态上不仅与体制化的基督教对立，而且与传统理解上的基督教道德基石对立。对强者应向弱者履行的照顾职责的同情，以及跨越性别、种族、社会地位或任何背景的共同人类尊严感。而显而易见的是，纳粹主义绝对鄙视这两条原则。确实如此。我选择这个真是犯了个大错误，汤姆，因为这给了你一个骑上你最喜欢的言论高马的机会。不过你是对的，你完全是对的。当然，基督教对每一个独立人类尊严和神圣性的强调……
of human life and all that stuff could not be more implacably opposed to the values of the nazi regime in the in the middle of the second world war now that that leaf number four it ends with the words we very famously we will not be silent we are your bad conscience the white rose will not leave you in peace but actually the funny thing is that why i was then kind of do leave people in peace because they've done four leaflets. They haven't really achieved, you know, there's been no mass uprising. There's no demonstrations, nothing. Their student life continues.
人类生命及种种相关价值，在第二次世界大战中期，与纳粹政权的价值观可以说是水火不容。现在，第四份传单以这样的话语结尾：我们非常出名的话语是——我们绝不沉默，我们是你们良心的谴责，白玫瑰绝不会让你们安宁。但实际上，有趣的是，为什么我当时说他们确实没有让人们安宁，因为他们已经写了四份传单。他们并没有真正取得什么成就，你知道的，没有发生大规模起义。没有游行示威，什么都没有。他们的学生生活仍在继续。
Three of them, Hans, Vili and Alex, they're sent as medics to the Eastern Front. Sophie is conscripted to go back to Ulm to work in an armaments factory. I mean, the thing that's interesting about that also, talking about how there are groups within Nazi Germany that presaged the teenage revolution. But this is, I mean, also they are students. That must be important, mustn't it? I mean, that's a prefiguring of the role that students will play in the 60s. The sort of idealism, I suppose, but also the...
他们中的三人，汉斯、维利和亚历克斯，被派往东线担任医疗兵。苏菲则被强征回到乌尔姆的一家军工厂工作。我的意思是，这件事有趣的地方在于，这也谈到了纳粹德国内部那些预示着青少年革命的群体。但这也是指，他们同时也是学生。这一定很重要，不是吗？我的意思是，这是60年代学生将要扮演角色的先兆。我想，这是一种理想主义，但也包含了……
The idealism and the radicalism and the sense that you're sticking it to the man. Yeah. And to students in the 60s, the idea that the French or the American authorities are fascist is very important. Oh, of course it is. I mean, this is what people say all the time in Germany in the 1960s and 70s and the Baader-Meinhof kind of people. Yeah. this is what people say all the time in Germany in the 1960s and 70s and the Baader-Meinhof kind of people. That there's no difference between the fascism of the third Reich and the fascism of, you know,
理想主义、激进主义，以及那种你要跟当权者死磕到底的感觉。是的。对60年代的学生来说，法国或美国当局是法西斯的这种想法非常重要。哦，当然重要。我的意思是，这就是德国在20世纪60、70年代以及巴德-迈因霍夫那类人总是挂在嘴边的话。是的。这也是德国在20世纪60、70年代以及巴德-迈因霍夫那类人总是挂在嘴边的话。那就是第三帝国的法西斯主义与你知道的……
Gerald Ford's America. But the Scholls, I mean, are impressive because they literally are taking on fascists. But also it's, they, they use that word, they use the expression passive resistance,
杰拉尔德·福特的美国的法西斯主义没有任何区别。但绍尔兄妹，我的意思是，他们令人印象深刻，是因为他们实实在在地在与法西斯抗争。但同时也是因为他们，他们用了那个词，他们用了“消极抵抗”这个表述，
I think in leaflet number four, perhaps because of their interesting kind of religious stuff and whatnot, that they've got an interest in Gandhi or they've known what's been happening in India. Well, I imagine also that they are influenced by the tradition of Catholic pacifism. Yeah, I'm sure that's right. There's absolutely no hint at any point that they would consider violence i mean that's obviously the difference with the students of the 60s and 70s where you know in every country virtually you have a tiny tiny group that is so radicalized but also to be against violence in the context of fascism is the most radical step you can take agreed so sophie's back in ulm. Her father, Robert, I mean, he knows nothing of this, but at this point, he actually is sent to prison briefly for having sounded off against Hitler. So he's been informed upon he's sentaments factory, alongside a lot of forced laborers from Russia. So the war is being kind of brought home to her.
我想是在第四份传单里，也许是因为他们那种有趣的宗教背景之类的，他们对甘地产生了兴趣，或者他们了解了印度正在发生的事情。嗯，我想他们也受到了天主教和平主义传统的深远影响。是的，我敢肯定确实如此。在任何时候，他们都绝对没有表现出考虑过暴力的迹象。我的意思是，这显然是他们与60和70年代学生的区别所在。你知道，在几乎每一个国家，你都会有一小撮极端激进化的群体，但在法西斯主义的背景下，反暴力可以说是你能采取的最激进的一步。完全同意。所以苏菲回到了乌尔姆。她的父亲罗伯特，我的意思是，他对这一切毫不知情，但就在此时，他实际上因为发表了反对希特勒的言论而被短暂送进了监狱。所以他遭到了告发，他被送往军工厂，和许多来自俄罗斯的强迫劳工在一起。因此，这场战争算是被带到了她的身边。
That autumn, later that autumn, her brother and his friends, they return to Germany from the Eastern Front. They never really talk about what they've seen or what they've done. But, you know, it doesn't take much imagination to speculate that they, even if they haven't necessarily seen terrible things, they'll undoubtedly have heard of them from other people on the front. Sophie's fiancé Fritz, I mentioned in the first half, he has now been transferred to Stalingrad.
那年秋天，那年秋天晚些时候，她的哥哥和他的朋友们从东线回到了德国。他们从未真正谈论过他们所见所闻或所做过的事。但是，你知道的，不需要太多的想象力就能推测出，即使他们没有亲眼目睹可怕的事情，他们也无疑从前线的其他人那里听说过。苏菲的未婚夫弗里茨，我在前半部分提到过，现在已经被调往斯大林格勒了。
Blimey. So, you know, they've really been sort of sucked into the war. They all assemble back in Munich later that autumn. Munich has had its first direct air raid at the end of October, Allied air raid. So morale generally in Germany is plummeting in the final months of 1942. There's a real sense of kind of urgency, of looming disaster, of a kind of final confrontation and all this kind of stuff ragnarok got a dameron exactly exactly they feel at this point okay let's let's restart the white
天哪。所以，你知道的，他们真的被卷入了这场战争。那年秋天晚些时候，他们都在慕尼黑重新集结。慕尼黑在10月底经历了第一次直接空袭，盟军的空袭。因此，在1942年的最后几个月，德国的士气普遍在暴跌。有一种真正的紧迫感，一种迫在燃眉的灾难感，一种终极对决的感觉，诸如此类。诸神黄昏，同归于尽，完全如此。他们在这个时候觉得，好吧，让我们重新开始白
rose let's get it back up and running but also let's make it more political we need to reach more people more places we need to forge links they know they've heard rumors that there are other similar groups in other places there are maybe more overtly kind of more secular, more overtly political kind of left-wing groups of people meeting and talking about overthrowing the regime, talking about what comes next, all of this stuff. So they're keen to link up with all these groups. And they decide to do a new leaflet. So that comes out at the beginning of 1943, January 43. This is leaflet number five. They don't call themselves the White Rose. The leaflets are headed leaflets of the resistance movement in Germany. Leaflet number five begins with the
玫瑰，让我们让它重新运转起来，但同时，我们要让它更具政治性。我们需要接触更多的人，更多的地方，我们需要建立联系。他们知道，他们听到传闻说其他地方还有其他类似的群体。可能还有更多公开的、更世俗的、更具政治性的左翼群体，人们在那里开会讨论推翻政权，讨论接下来该做什么，诸如此类的事情。所以他们渴望与所有这些群体建立联系。他们决定制作一份新传单。所以这在1943年年初、43年1月问世了。这就是第五份传单。他们不称自己为白玫瑰。传单的标题是“德国抵抗运动传单”。第五份传单以
words, a call to all Germans. It talks about how Germany should be federalized. The working class must be liberated from its degraded conditions of slavery by a form of socialism. It talks about human rights. It talks about what a new Germany would look like after the war. So it's a bit less Christian and it's a bit more political.
这样的话开头：发给所有德国人的呼吁。它谈到了德国应该如何实行联邦制。工人阶级必须通过某种形式的社会主义，从被剥夺权力的奴役状态中解放出来。它谈到了人权。它谈到了战后一个新德国会是什么样子。所以它不那么具有基督教色彩，而更具政治性。
There's also a lot more of these. So they produce about 10,000 copies of this leaflet, and that is 20 times more than any of the others. And what they do, this is the first leaflet that really gets the Gestapo alarmed because it's spread beyond Munich. And the Gestapo actually get their guy called Robert Moore. He is told, okay, get to the bottom of who these White Rose people are and what's
而且这类的数量也多得多。因此，他们印制了大约1万份这种传单，这比其他任何传单的数量都要多出20倍。他们所做的，这是第一份真正让盖世太保感到惊慌的传单，因为它已经传播到了慕尼黑以外的地方。盖世太保甚至派出了一个名叫罗伯特·莫尔的人。他接到命令：好吧，去查清楚这些白玫瑰成员到底是谁，以及到底发生了
going on. And when he looks into it, he sees the leaflets are appearing all over Germany. They found them in Stuttgart, they found them in Ulm, they found them in Frankfurt, they found them in Augsburg, they found them in Berlin. They've even found them in Vienna, which has of course been incorporated into Germany after the Anschluss. How are they getting there? Well, this is a brilliant scheme by the members of the white rose what they do is they will pack their bags full of leaflets then they get on a train they put the bag in a different carriage from the one they're in so that if the bag is discovered they won't be yeah they're not suspected but what they do is they go to a different city and they post the
什么。当他调查时，他发现传单在德国各地出现。他们在斯图加特发现了，在乌尔姆发现了，在法兰克福发现了，在奥格斯堡发现了，在柏林发现了。他们甚至在维也纳也发现了，维也纳在德奥合并后当然已经被并入了德国。他们是怎么到达那里的？嗯，这是白玫瑰成员的一个绝妙计划。他们的做法是，把行李箱装满传单，然后他们登上火车，把行李箱放在他们所在的那个车厢之外的另一个车厢里，这样如果行李箱被发现，他们就不会被——是的，他们不会被怀疑。但他们做的是，他们去另一个城市，把
leaflets from there to yet another city so So in other words, you go to Vienna with a thousand leaflets and you post leaflets from there to Frankfurt. So in other words, there's no link to Munich and there's no link to them. So Sophie, for example, she goes, gets on the train, she goes to Augsburg, she goes to Stuttgart, and she sends herself about 800 leaflets from there all over Germany. So the Gestapo are furious about this. I mean, the leaflets are now becoming, there's now enough of them that they're becoming a bit of a story and they're keen to stamp them out. What is more, very soon after these leaflets start appearing, the Germans surrender at Stalingrad. Including Sophie's boyfriend? He was at Stalingrad, right?
传单从那里寄到又一个城市。所以换句话说，你带着一千份传单去维也纳，然后从那里把传单寄到法兰克福。换句话说，这与慕尼黑没有联系，与他们本人也没有联系。所以，举个例子，苏菲上车去奥格斯堡，去斯图加特，然后从那里给自己寄了大约800份传单到德国各地。因此，盖世太保对此愤怒至极。我的意思是，这些传单现在开始变得——数量多到已经变成了一条新闻，他们急于将其彻底铲除。不仅如此，就在这些传单开始出现后不久，德军在斯大林格勒投降了。包括苏菲的男朋友吗？他当时在斯大林格勒，对吧？
He had been, but no. He had been invalided out to a Polish hospital. Like so many Germans on the Eastern Front, he had suffered severe frostbite, Tom, and his hand had had to be amputated. Oh, no.
他去过，但没有。他已经被遣送到波兰的一家医院。汤姆，就像东线上的许多德国人一样，他遭到了严重的冻伤，他的手不得不被截肢。哦，不。
Yeah. So he actually survives this whole story, Fritz Harden-Eagle. He became a judge later in life he died in 2001 would you believe by me so that sort of slightly messes with the sense of time yeah anyway so uh actually when stalingrad fell hans and his mates went out and they painted on the on the walls around the university um the words freedom and down with hitler um which is an extraordinarily how much courage would you yeah i was about to say brave and and reckless i suppose
是的。所以他实际上在这整个故事中活了下来，弗里茨·哈登-埃格尔。他后来成为了一名法官，你敢信吗，他于2001年去世，天哪。所以这有点打乱了时间感。无论如何，呃，实际上，当斯大林格勒陷落时，汉斯和他的伙伴们走出去，在大学周围的墙上涂写了“自由”和“打倒希特勒”字样，
you would say a thing to do so that's the third of february that stein grads the news of stein grads surrender starts to percolate percolates exactly there's then a sixth leaflet and they go out they go out a couple more times actually to write down with hitler on the walls and so on and freedom and all this kind of thing and then it's the 18th of february where we began the podcast with hans and sophie going in with these so they've got these suitcases full of leaflets they go into the university building they distribute the leaflets and then this act which i suppose you can only describe as reckless do you think they wanted to be caught i mean to there's a kind of martyrdom i did wonder that tom because when the guy schmidt the caretaker as far as we can tell as i said the doors open
这极其——你需要多大的勇气，汤姆，我正要说勇敢而且鲁莽，我想你会说是这样一种行为。所以那是2月3日，斯大林格勒，斯大林格勒投降的消息开始传开，传开，正是如此。随后又有了第六份传单，他们走出去，实际上又出去写了几次“打倒希特勒”之类的标语，还有“自由”以及诸如此类的事情。然后就到了2月18日，也就是我们播客开篇的那天，汉斯和苏菲带着装满传单的手提箱进入大学大楼，散发传单，然后就是这个行为，我想你只能用鲁莽来形容。你觉得他们是想被抓吗？我的意思是，有一种殉道的情结。我确实想过这一点，汤姆，因为当那个看门人施密特，据我们所知，正如我所说，门开了，
loads of students came out and they tried to lose themselves in the crowd then he shouted to them again stop you're under arrest and they then did stop this like they froze but also the cunning with which they you know they're going to all these different cities and then on to other cities and so on to cover their tracks and then they're standing in a university throwing yeah the flyers out i mean it's is it high spiritedness is it recklessness is it as you said is is it a desire for a subconscious desire for martyrdom? It's really hard to tell. So the guy who I mentioned a little while ago, Robert Moore, the Gestapo guy, he gets a call from the university. They say, over. They don't seem nervous. They don't seem anxious or anything like that. He talks to them. They give their names.
大量的学生涌出来，他们试图在人群中隐匿自己。然后他又对他们大喊：站住，你们被捕了。然后他们真的停了下来，就像僵住了一样。但同时，他们去所有这些不同的城市，然后又去其他城市等等以掩盖行踪，这种狡猾与他们在大学里站着到处扔传单的行为——我的意思是，这是年少轻盛吗？是鲁莽吗？正如你所说，这是一种渴望，一种潜意识里的殉道渴望吗？真的很难说。所以，我刚才提到过的那个人，盖世太保罗伯特·莫尔，接到了来自大学的电话。他们说，结束了。他们看起来并不紧张。他们看起来不焦虑或任何诸如此类的情绪。他与他们交谈。他们报上了姓名。
They say, oh, no, it's nothing to do with us. He doesn't believe at first they're the culprits because they're clearly well-educated, from good families, middle class, all of this sort of stuff. He thinks, oh, it can't be these people. He says, well, why are you walking around with an empty suitcase?
他们说，哦，不，这跟我们没关系。他起初不相信他们是罪魁祸首，因为他们显然受过良好教育，来自好家庭，中产阶级，所有这些。他想，哦，不可能是这些人。他说，好吧，你提着一个空手提箱到处走干什么？
And they say, oh, we were going to go back to Ulm on the train, and we were going to pick up stuff from home, new clothes, and bring it back to Munich, so we needed to take it empty. You know, it all kind of vaguely makes sense. But at that point, his men have collected all the leaflets, and they try to fit them in the suitcase, and they find that they fit perfectly, which is a bad sign. And about that point, Moore says, well, we'll take them and ask them a few more questions and hands pulls up
他们说，哦，我们要坐火车回乌尔姆，打算从家里拿点东西，新衣服，然后带回慕尼黑，所以我们需要带一个空箱子去。你知道，这一切听起来都勉强说得通。但在那个时候，他的手下已经收集了所有的传单，并试图把它们塞进手提箱里，结果发现它们完美契合，这是一个不祥之兆。大约在这个时候，莫尔说，好吧，我们带走他们，再问几个问题。而汉斯却掏出了
i mean very foolishly i would say um although it's easy for me to say from here he pulls a piece of paper from his pocket and shoves it in his mouth and starts to chew it which is a dead giveaway and that's actually a draft for yet another leaflet that his friend Christoph has been writing. So at that point, they're handcuffed. They're taken through the crowds outside for interrogation. Moore decides he will interrogate Sophie personally. And what's interesting is he says to her, he tries to give her a get out. So he says to her, I imagine that you don't really believe in all the stuff that your brother's led you into he's probably been you know tricking you yeah he he wants her to say brother splaining you're right yeah exactly and she says you are wrong i would do it all over again because i'm
我的意思是，我得说这是极其愚蠢的做法，尽管我坐在这里说这话很容易。他从口袋里掏出一张纸，塞进嘴里开始咀嚼。这绝对是不打自招的铁证，而那实际上正是他的朋友克里斯托夫一直在写的一份新传单的草稿。就在那时，他们被戴上手铐。他们穿过外面的重重人群被带去审讯。莫尔决定亲自审讯苏菲。有趣的是，他对她说，他试图给她一条退路。所以他对她说，我想你并不真的相信你哥哥把你引向的那一切，他大概是——你知道的，在哄骗你。是的。他希望她说：哥哥对我的洗脑。你是对的。是的，完全如此。而她却说：你错了，我会把这一切再做一遍，因为我
not wrong it is you who are wrong and at that point you know it's pretty obvious how this story is going to end so the narcissists have got the two shells and they've got their friend Christoph, whose paper Hans had been trying to chew up. And there's amazing sort of stories, very moving stories from, for example, Sophie's cellmate about her looking out through the barred windows at the sunshine, you know, talking to herself and saying, how many are dying? How many young lives full of hope?
没有错，错的是你们。就在那时，你知道的，这个故事将如何结局就显而易见了。所以纳粹逮捕了绍尔兄妹和他们的朋友克里斯托夫，汉斯刚才一直在试图把克里斯托夫写的纸嚼碎。还有一些非常惊人的故事，非常感人的故事，比如来自苏菲的狱友的回忆，讲述她透过带铁栏的窗户看着阳光，自言自语地说：“有多少人在死去？有多少充满希望的年轻生命？”
What difference will my death make if our actions arouse thousands of people and all this kind of stuff? Very idealistic. February the 22nd, which is four days after the event, they are taken from their cells and they are taken for trial.
“如果我们的行动能唤醒成千上万的人，我的死又算得了什么呢？”诸如此类的话。非常理想主义。2月22日，也就是事发四天后，他们被带出牢房，接受审判。
Afterwards, Sophie Selmay finds on her bed um sophie has left a piece of paper with a single word written on it which is freedom in hans's cell i mean it's all it's very hollywood in a way because it's so kind of inspiring um hans has written in pencil on the wall, despite all the powers closing in, hold yourself up, which is his father's favorite line from Goethe. So they're taken for trial. The judge is a guy called Roland Freisler, who is a fanatical Nazi, and he finds them guilty and pronounces the death sentence. And they don't really say anything until the end when Friesler says, your sentence to death. Hans just says, you will soon stand where we stand now. So they're taken off to Stadelheim prison, where the executions will take place. Somehow,
事后，苏菲的狱友在她的床上发现——苏菲留下一张纸条，上面只写了一个词，那就是“自由”。在汉斯的牢房里，我的意思是，这一切在某种程度上非常像好莱坞电影，因为它是如此鼓舞人心。汉斯用铅笔在墙上写道：“在所有逼近的力量面前，挺直腰杆。”这是他父亲最喜欢的歌德的名言。所以他们被带去受审。法官是一个名叫罗兰·弗赖斯勒的人，他是一个狂热的纳粹分子，他判定他们有罪并宣判死刑。他们什么也没多说，直到最后弗赖斯勒宣判说：“判处你们死刑。”汉斯只是说：“你们很快也会站在我们现在站的地方。”于是他们被带到施塔德尔海姆监狱，行刑将在那里进行。不知何故，
I don't really know how, to be completely honest, their parents managed to persuade the authorities to let them see them one last time. they go in i mean this is incredibly moving to read about so robert shull goes in and meets hans and hugs him and says you'll go down in history you know everybody one day will know your name and know that there is justice in the world then his then they get to see sophie her mother has brought her some sweets. Hans didn't want the sweets, but Sophie takes them. Does it remind how young they are? Yeah.
老实说我真的不知道怎么做到的，他们的父母设法说服当局让他们见孩子们最后一次面。他们进去了，我的意思是，读到这些真是令人无比动容。罗伯特·绍尔走进去见到汉斯，拥抱了他并说道：“你会名垂青史的，你知道的，总有一天每个人都会知道你的名字，知道这个世界上还有正义。”然后他的——接着他们去见苏菲。她的母亲给她带了一些糖果。汉斯不想要糖果，但苏菲收下了。这难道不会让人想起他们有多年轻吗？是的。
Mrs. Scholl supposedly says to Sophie, Oh, Sophie, Sophie, you'll never come in the door again. And Sophie says, Oh, mother, but what are those few years anyway? And then her mother says, Sophie, remember Jesus. Sophie says, Yes, you too. And then she's taken away. And she, more the Gestapo guy, later goes past her son mother says, Sophie, remember Jesus. Sophie says, yes, you too. And then she's taken away. And she, more the Gestapo guy, later goes past her cell and says he sees her weeping in her cell. They're given access to a Protestant priest, a chaplain, who comes and reads Psalms with them.
据说绍尔夫人对苏菲说：“哦，苏菲，苏菲，你再也进不了这扇门了。”苏菲说：“哦，妈妈，不过那短短几年又算得了什么呢？”然后她的母亲说：“苏菲，记住耶稣。”苏菲说：“是的，你也是。”然后她就被带走了。她，盖世太保莫尔后来从她的牢房走过时说，他看到她在牢房里哭泣。他们被允许见一位新教牧师、一位随军牧师，牧师进来和他们一起诵读圣诗。
They take communion. They're taken out. They're taken into the courtyard. The guillotine is there. It's five o'clock in the afternoon. Sophie is executed first. And Hans, just before Hans is executed, he shouts, long live freedom. And then the blade comes down. And you might say that's the end of the story, but it isn't. Because in 1943, there are all kinds of roundings up of resistance people. So it's impossible actually to put a real figure on how many people were
他们领了圣餐。他们被带了出去。他们被带进庭院。断头台就在那里。当时是下午五点。苏菲第一个被处决。而汉斯在被处决前不久，大喊了一声：“自由万岁！”随后刀刃落下。你可能会说这是故事的结局，但事实并非如此。因为在1943年，发生了各种针对抵抗运动人员的大搜捕。所以实际上根本不可能给出一个确切的数字，说明有多少人因
rounded up as a direct result of this, but obviously quite a number. But news of this, the Nazis tried to suppress news of it. But obviously in their deaths, the White Rose Movement won a victory. They win their martyrdom. They win their martyrdom in a way that their leaflets probably never would have done. So Thomas Mann, I mentioned Sophie reading The Magic Mountain. Thomas Mann, who was, of course, in America, he writes an article about their deaths not long afterwards.
此直接遭到搜捕，但显然数量相当多。纳粹试图压制关于此事的任何消息，但显然，在他们死后，白玫瑰运动赢得了一场胜利。他们赢得了殉道。他们以一种他们散发的传单可能永远无法做到的方式赢得了殉道。所以我刚才提到苏菲在读《魔山》的托马斯·曼，当时身在美国的托马斯·曼不久后就发表了一篇文章，谈到了他们的死。
A new faith in freedom and honor is dawning. Good, splendid young people, you shall not have died in vain. You shall not be forgotten. The Nazis have raised monuments to indecent rogues and common killers, but the German revolution, the the real revolution will tear them down and in their place will memorialize these people who knew and publicly declared that a new faith was dawning and all this kind of stuff don't the raf drop copies of the pamphlets i hadn't heard that story tom is that true that's a great story it was all about the intersection of the raf and the firebombing, but also the...
对自由与荣誉的新信念正在破晓。好样的，了不起的年轻人，你们没有白白牺牲。你们不会被遗忘。纳粹为无耻的恶棍和普通的杀手建立纪念碑，但德国革命，真正的革命将推倒这些纪念碑，并在它们的位置上纪念这些人，他们深知并公开宣告一种新的信念正在破晓，诸如此类。英国皇家空军不是投撒了这些小册子的副本吗？我没听过这个故事，汤姆，那是真的吗？那真是一个极好的故事。这完全关乎皇家空军与轰炸的交织，但也关于……
Do you know, Tom? It is true. It is true. Yes, I thought it was. So I was going to kind of work that into the chapter, and then I didn't because I didn't include the shoals. Some people consider this a terribly banal end to this podcast, but I've just checked it and there's a Daily Mail story about it in 2011.
你知道吗，汤姆？这是真的。这是真的。是的，我想是的。所以本来我想把这个写进这一章里，但后来没有写，因为我没有把绍尔兄妹的故事写进去。有些人可能会认为这是本期播客一个非常平庸的结尾，但我刚刚查过了，2011年《每日邮报》上有一篇关于它的报道。
Blimey. That, yes, in July 1943, copies of this final leaflet were dropped over Germany by Allied aircraft, which is a sign of how much the story had spread. I mean, the story that I always like comes from the quotation is, there was a half-Jewish Austrian poet
天哪。是的，1943年7月，盟军飞机在德国上空投撒了最后这份传单的副本，这表明这个故事已经传播得多么广泛。我的意思是，我一直很喜欢的那个故事来自于一句引言，有一个奥地利犹太混血女诗人
called Ilse Eichinger, a very left-wing poet. The Germans had done their best to suppress, the poet. The Germans had done their best to suppress, the authorities rather had done their best to suppress, you know, knowledge of what's to happen to Hans and Sophie Scholl. But one day, Ilse Eichinger said later, she saw a poster on the wall with the names of the White Rose and the people who had been sentenced to death.
叫伊尔泽·艾兴格，一位非常左翼的诗人。德国人尽了最大努力去压制——那个诗人。德国人尽了最大努力去压制——准确地说是当局尽了最大努力去压制有关汉斯和苏菲·绍尔遭遇的知情权。但有一天，伊尔泽·艾兴格后来回忆说，她在墙上看到了一张海报，上面写着白玫瑰以及那些被判处死刑的人的名字。
She said, I read the names on the poster. I'd never heard of any of them. But as I read those names, an inexpressible hope leaped up in me. And I was not the only one who felt this way. This hope was not just the hope for our survival. It helped so many that still had to die that even they could die with hope. It was like a secret light that expanded over the world. It was joy.
她说：“我读着海报上的名字。这些名字我以前从未听说过。但当我读到这些名字时，一股无法言喻的希望在我心中涌起。而且不只是我有这种感觉。这份希望不仅仅是对我们自己能够生还的希望。它给予了许多不得不赴死的人巨大的力量，让他们甚至能怀着希望死去。它就像一道秘密的光芒，在世界上蔓延开来。那是喜悦。”
And that, in a way, is how the White Rose had been remembered. That in this sort of, is how the White Rose had been remembered, that even in the deepest darkness, there was still a candle lit. And to this day, of course, they're almost, dare I say, sacred figures in post-war Germany. I think you could absolutely say that. You know, streets are named after them. There are memorials, there are prizes. If you go to the University of Munich, to the place where they were arrested, outside that building, there are piles of leaflets as memorials to their courage. So if you go to that university today as a student, you literally walk past piles of the leaflets. They are incredibly moving and inspirational figures.
从某种意义上说，这就是白玫瑰被人们铭记的方式。在某种程度上，这就是白玫瑰被铭记的方式：即便在最深重的黑暗中，依然有一支蜡烛在燃烧。直到今天，他们在战后的德国当然几乎成了——我敢说——神圣的人物。我想你完全可以这么说。你知道，街道以他们的名字命名，有纪念碑，有各种奖项。如果你去慕尼黑大学，去他们被捕的地方，那个建筑的外墙外面，堆满了作为纪念他们勇气的传单。所以如果你今天作为一名学生去那所大学，你字面意义上就是从那一叠叠传单旁走过。他们是极其感人和鼓舞人心的人物。
And the fact they're so young. Yeah. So young. Such courage. Great episode, Dominic. We're normally much more flippant than this, aren't we? Well, we have many different tones. There's good in us.
而且他们还那么年轻。是的。如此年轻。如此勇敢。精彩的一期，多米尼克。我们平时可没这么严肃认真，对吧？嗯，我们有很多不同的基调。我们内心也有好的一面。
There's good in us too, you know. That's the main message to take away. It's a fabulous story and a great choice. And thank you for doing it. And I hope that you all enjoyed it too. And obviously we will be back, probably with something slightly less heroic and inspirational. But who knows?
你知道的，我们内心也有好的一面。这是需要带走的主要信息。这是一个绝妙的故事，也是一个极好的选择。谢谢你给我们讲述这个故事。我希望大家也都喜欢。显然我们会回来的，可能会带来一些不那么英勇悲壮、不那么鼓舞人心的内容。但谁知道呢？
I can't tell. We don't know what order these are all going out in. So who knows, but we'll see you tomorrow. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes,
我猜不到。我们也不知道这些节目播出的先后顺序。所以谁知道呢，但我们明天见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家番外节目、
early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目以及优先获得现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。